tormenta diplomática entre Israel y
Australia desatada tras la decisión del
gobierno del Primer Ministro australiano
el laborista Anthony Albany de reversar
la decisión de reconocer a Jerusalén del
Oeste como la capital israelí hoy el
gobierno ha reafirmado la posición
anterior y de larga Data de Australia de
que Jerusalén es una cuestión de estatus
final y una cuestión que debe resolverse
como parte de cualquier negociación de
paz entre Israel y los pueblos
palestinos
esta decisión fue criticada duramente
por el Primer Ministro de israelí y Yair
lapid que considera que tomar ese camino
fue precipitado por parte de Australia y
convocará a su embajador y los
australianos ni nadie va a decidir Cuál
es la capital de Israel en los últimos
tres mil años Jerusalén siempre ha sido
la capital de Israel y seguirá
haciéndolo el anterior ministro
australiano Scott Morrison había
reconocido en 2018 a la ciudad en
disputa como capital aunque no trasladó
su embajada desde tel aviv como si lo
hizo el ex presidente Donald Trump en
2017 lo que causó una controversia
internacional al desconocer los derechos
palestinos sobre los territorios que
reclama como propios y donde pretende si
se llega a un acuerdo volver la capital
y Donde hay lugares sagrados de las tres
grandes religiones la cristiana La judía
y la musulmana por su parte el
Ministerio de asuntos exteriores
palestino aplaudió la decisión
australiana
creemos que al hacer esto Australia ha
corregido su posición errónea que fue
tomada por el gobierno anterior y
reconsiderada con el fin de alinearse
con el derecho internacional
Estados Unidos Guatemala y kosovo tienen
embajada en Jerusalén